this is louise brown and she read a lot
between 1946 and 2009 she borrowed and
read 12 books a week every week from her
favorite library almost finishing all of
the books there that's over 25 000 of
them even at 91 when her eyesight was
impaired she just picked books larger
text now that's absolutely incredible
and while louise said that she just
loved reading a lot so many of us
struggle with finding the motivation
time and technique to consistently make
reading habits we've made a routine of
leaving people but not books unread and
so to rectify this here are four
mistakes that you may be making when it
comes to becoming an effective book
reader
i'm going to talk about what we read how
we read how we structure our life around
reading and how we approach the actual
books that we're using so let's jump
straight in the first mistake is reading
a single book at the time and this is so
bizarre to me it's almost like being
forced to eat the same thing for
breakfast lunch and dinner every single
day which you would just get so bored of
at some point even when we were in
school we were reading multiple books
slowly at once there was a physics book
and a maths book and a biology book and
a chemistry book and we were able to
kind of continue paying attention to all
of these or for example there are so
many people in our lives and we remember
exactly what's going on in the
trajectory of theirs and what's
happening to them all at the same time i
don't know why we seem to have this
impression sometimes that we should only
read a single book at a time if you want
to make it more likely that you do
something and hopefully that you enjoy
that thing it's much easier to make it
something that is more pleasurable
versus russell in his essay appraisal of
idleness said that good nature so being
able to do something positively is a
result of enjoying the process rather
than continuous struggle how this
translates to reading for me is that at
different times of the day or the week i
have a different sort of mood or vibe
and if i have just one single book that
i have to finish i might just not be in
the mood for reading that book rather
than not being in the mood for reading
at all any given time in my life i
always have one good business book one
bad business book one philosophy book
one good psychology book one bad
psychology book one good non-fiction
book one bad non-fiction book harry
potter and sometimes a science book just
running in the background as options
that i can pick from oh and also
sometimes a book that someone else will
have recommended to me that might be
quite random this is r at any given time
i will be in the mood for reading at
least one of these books as tiago forte
says the scarce's resource is interest
and desire so having interest at any
time for reading is the most key thing
that you need to latch on rather than
something specific that you're forcing
yourself to do instead of people who are
prolific writers loveman found that many
of them were working on multiple
manuscripts at a time so they said that
they were never not in the mood for
writing they would just switch onto
something else so they had almost
infinite sources of energy and i find
that reading multiple books at once and
picking the one that you are in the mood
for at the moment makes it much more
likely that you read in general rather
than thinking hmm i'm not in the mood
for reading that one book so i must not
be in the mood for reading at all the
second mistake i see made quite often is
reading a good book only once and this
to me is the equivalent of listening to
an amazing song once and going oh i'm
never going to hear that again rather
than saving it to your spotify like
songs and listening to it and repeat
again and again and again even though
life itself is quite fruiting as
frederick nietzsche said we are destined
to play this world only a passing visit
a gracious reminder of life rather than
life itself but books give us the
opportunity to reapproach life not in
this vast pleating way but in a slow
reappreciating way that gives us the
space to rethink and we see things again
and again and again also what i realized
is that i almost never read the same
book twice because the book is reading
me as much as i am reading it what that
means is i'm always a different person
and what i get from the book is what i
think about it rather some objective
truth that is in the book itself so
because i change so much and because i
grow so much or just because i'm in a
different mood or in a different mindset
it's almost a different person that
reapproaches the same book every time
and if there's something great or
incredible in it
it's so worth going back to it again and
again and always getting new things from
the book past put this perfectly when he
said one cannot read a novel without
describing to the heroine the traits of
the one that we love so we are always
reading books with our own lens and that
lens continuously changes it's also
pretty crazy how long it actually takes
to write a good book and there are
months or years or decades sometimes of
someone's life that just get condensed
in something that i decide to read in
five hours which is just crazy obviously
i'm not taking everything from it but if
you're someone who likes to read quite a
lot then if you find something good it's
good to reapproach it and see what else
you may have missed there often i like
to approach books like old friends and i
like to catch up with them and kind of
get reminded of who i was the last time
that i read the book and see how much
i've grown and take more from it or in
the opposite end i can sometimes use
books to ground me to the person that i
want to be or the thing that i want to
do so i can use them either as a
constant or as a growth method but
either way reapproaching books is just
so underrated the next mistake i see
being made quite often is not taking
notes from books and now i feel really
passionately about note-taking and i do
not mean just underlining things writing
things or taking notes from books for
the purpose of those notes if that makes
sense there's so many companies out
there i love short form for example but
there's so many different things that
already kind of
shorten down books and take notes from
books and everything is on quotes on
google and stuff there's no point in
rewriting things down or resaving things
or highlighting things for absolutely no
reason what i mean by note taking is
actually the action of approaching the
book in a more intentional sort of way
and for example thinking what are the
projects in my life that i am currently
working on for which i would want more
information or how am i trying to change
myself or what am i trying to grow or
what am i trying to do so let's say for
example that i think that i'm a bit
insecure and i want to become a more
confident person i might use this lens
when i'm reading a book to see either
confident characters or characters who
become more confident and see what are
their attributes what are their traits
and how have they grown and why do i
think that they are shaped in this way
and what can they say about me so these
will be the kind of notes that i will be
taking from books understanding more
about other people in the world because
books will have so much more description
and explanation about them and in that
way understanding more about why i am
the way that i am i will almost always
approach books and especially note
taking from books in the way that how
can this change my life and how can this
re-shift or change my perspective on
things how is this different to how i
currently see the world or how does this
confirm the way that i currently see the
world the last mistake is a slightly
controversial one and that is not being
able to speed read or not using speed
reading sometimes in books now i feel
both ways about this for example proust
did say nelly patrice which means an
advantage of not going too fast is that
the world has a chance of becoming more
interesting in the process and i do
recognize that there is so much need for
kind of meditation and slow approach to
things that we are doing in life in this
time of kind of like rushing rushing
rushing but what i mean by speed reading
is using it as a superpower that will
get you through those parts of the books
that would have otherwise made you close
the book and never read it again it's
almost guaranteed that there will be
parts of a book that are just not taking
your interest at the time and that mean
that either you fall asleep or that you
switch to another activity or that you
just decide that this book is horrible
and you never want to see it again if
you could read you could go through
these parts of the book a lot faster and
then either think oh my god this was
actually really interesting i'm going to
reread this again slowly or realize that
oh no it's getting good again or then
realize oh no this is definitely not for
me and then leave the book at all but
having the ability to speed read makes
this a much more effective and likely
opportunity so many times i've talked to
people who say that they want to read
more but they're in the middle of the
book that they started three years ago
but the book was too slow and
uninteresting so they never finished it
i thought well if they could just speed
read the chapter that they're finding
boring then they could get to the more
interesting part without losing any part
of comprehension so if you want to learn
more about this skill actually i have a
video that i made recently on how i
speed read but that might be a skill
that if you have it in your repertoire
of how to read in general now i did
mention that i sometimes do read science
books in order to keep in touch with the
stem subjects but another thing that i
love to do to get the same kind of
information is to use brilliant which
are very kindly sponsoring this video
brilliant helps us learn using
interactivity which is so unique and
different to anything else that i've
been using before i'm currently doing
the everyday math science which is very
basic things but they're approached very
differently and sometimes i will be
honest i still do make some mistakes but
it's a great way for me to reapproach
and reassess subjects that i may not
have thought about in quite a long time
the front exercises makes it much more
interactive and much more likely that i
am sparking both curiosity and
creativity actually that spills into
other aspects of my life too if you also
want to check out brilliant with me the
first 200 people who will click the link
in the description will get a 20 of the
yearly subscription or you can just
check it out in the meantime as a last
note i just want to say i don't think
there's a right or wrong way of reading
but if you made it so far thank you so
much for spending this time with me i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be kind to yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye